three billboards outside Epping Missouri
was directed by Martin McDonagh the man
behind Seven Psychopaths and in Bruges -
excellent films if you've never seen
them this film is about a character
named Mildred played by Frances
McDormand who after the police and
ebbing Missouri failed to catch the
culprit of the man responsible for her
daughter's death puts up three
billboards asking the chief of police
played by Woody Harrelson why there have
been no arrests in this case and since
it's a very small rural town everyone
knows about it by the following day now
certain people are on the side of the
police and certain people are on Mildred
side but Mildred becomes an emotional
target for this entire town because they
feel the billboards are inappropriate
and it's a town that has no problem
saying quite a bit of inappropriate
things but when the spotlight is shone
on them for being complacent in the
solving of a very important crime while
also not being as complacent when it
comes to committing other crimes they
don't like that and so the film explores
a lot of deep dark territory and it does
so with a surprising amount of dark
humor this is one of the best films of
the year I think it's one of the best
acted films I've seen in many years
Frances McDorman is already a legend but
honestly this might be her best
performance her character is very driven
but she will not let anything stand in
her path she's one of the strongest
characters I've seen in a movie all year
she faces down an entire town that's
hating on her and telling her everything
she's doing is wrong
when all she's seeking is justice Woody
Harrelson as chief Willoughby is
typically excellent this is not his
first film with Martin McDonagh he was
also in Seven Psychopaths in fact a lot
of cast members from that film are
reused here like Sam Rockwell who plays
a racist bigoted cop who is basically
the definition of everything you don't
want an a police officer and his arc in
the film is probably my favorite he goes
through a lot and sees a lot which
brings me to probably my favorite aspect
of three billboards its unpredictability
the film plays out
in a way that I honestly did not expect
it to and characters make choices that
I'd
not see coming and plot points that you
expect to have specific answers to and
things that you are just expecting to
happen because we've all seen a ton of
movies they don't have him I try my
hardest not to predict how a movie's
going to end while I'm watching it but
after seeing so many sometimes you can
just think in your head like I know
what's about to happen in this scene
because you're used to the way scenes
and movies play out like if a character
in a horror movie opens up a
refrigerator you're expecting someone to
be standing behind that refrigerator
when they close it there are so many
moments in this movie particularly an
interrogation scene between Woody
Harrelson and Frances McDorman where
you're like I know where this is going
I've seen this a billion times oh holy
never mind and pretty much from there on
out I just stopped trying to analyze
where the film could lead because I was
always wrong I mentioned that the film
has some very bleak humor and that's not
going to be a surprise to anyone who's
ever seen in Martin McDonagh film and
here it was quite shocking characters
are not censored this is a small town in
a rural area and people say things
totally inappropriate and no one calls
them out on it for a long time because
that's just the way people in this town
talk there is no effort to distance
themselves from reality when it comes to
the script the characters all say things
and you're like jeez okay that's that
kind of movie and the film has really
clever ways and very ballsy ways of
making jokes out of things that a lot of
people are afraid to talk about today
and that's something that I have to
commend Martin McDonagh for because
there were moments where I cringed at
some of the humor and then in retrospect
thinking on it I even like man that was
actually really smart but it's not just
that humor that keeps the screenplay
fresh it's along with the performances a
very dark and heartfelt story that's
moving and powerful and that speaks
volumes about the way people react to
tragedies by trying to hide from them
and then when that tragedy is once again
forcibly put into the public's mind
suddenly everyone has a really hard time
dealing with that
because we all like to forget about
things when it's not us when we're
constantly forced to remember that
someone else is dealing with something
then it becomes a problem and this film
had a really great way of exploring that
I'm gonna give three billboards and a my
only issue with the film is sort of a
spoiler it's not really but it kind of
is so if you haven't seen the film yet
thanks for watching the video if you
have I'm gonna get into the only thing
that I wanted a little more out of and
that was the ending it's not that I
didn't like it I think I just wanted
maybe one more scene it's a little
ambiguous and in in a lot of films I
actually really like ambiguity but I
think in this story I was just so
invested and what was going to happen to
Mildred that I just wanted a little more
that's really it it's a fantastic film
definitely check it out guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]